it would not be opening day without a
special tradition unlike any other in
major league baseball
it's been a while since their last
appearance
but it's baseball season which means one
thing in st louis please welcome the
majestic hometown budweiser clydesdales
but what a sight
anytime we have the clydesdales at the
ballpark opening day
it is something to behold
the majestic clydesdale this year we
will celebrate the 50 years of mike
shannon in the broadcast booth
he's a native of st louis the voice of
the cardinals and one of the greatest
tours ever with the cardinals
organization
please look up to the broadcast move now
and salute
cardinals hall of famer mike shannon in
his final year
today we remember and pay tribute to the
loss of some cardinal greats
lou brock and bob gibson please join us
in observing a moment of silence to
remember these and other members of our
cardinals family and all others we've
lost over the past year
batting third number 28 third baseman
nolan arenado
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen our first pitch of
2021 a little different than normal
scott roland to nolan arenado
[Applause]
[Music]
this is a very familiar spot for old
number 50 adam wainwright making his
sixth opening day home start
what a beautiful thing it's gonna be a
great scene today
colton wong back in st louis
at seven opening days
wearing the birds on the bats leading
off the game for the brewers number 16
second baseman colton wong you might
want to go after colten wong right now
because he might be a little emotional
you could tell right there you see the
emotion flowing for colton that was a
really really cool cool debut there
so four straight and a walk to wong
so a hit batter and the bases will be
loaded for lorenzo kane
fly ball
left center
carlson over
he got it oh what a catch by dylan
carlson
and he robs lorenzo kane fist pump from
bueno
and corbin burns struck out 11 in his
debut against the minnesota twins went
six in a third
and he is awfully good
and edmond hits it in the gap in the
left center that ball is down he's off
to the races
on the second
oh on his way to third lead off triple
in the home opener tommy edmond
about a good at bat you fight off a
couple of pitches that you can't get to
you get one out over that you can handle
and as you mentioned tommy edmond off to
the races yelling looks like he gets
there ball just gets over his glove and
that has to feel good for casting here
to see some results here's yelich who
flied out to left back in the first
inning he's over one so far this
afternoon wainwright looking at hira
and this one thrown into center field on
the pickoff attempt and it gets by
carlson and here is going to be waved in
and he will score the game's first run
how about that yeah there's two errors
at first they're probably on the throw
second air on the center fielder well
the brewers take advantage there's a
shoddy defense
corbin burns 37 pitches through the
first couple of innings four strikeouts
that's part of the reason why
the pitch and he blew a fastball by him
at 95 for strikeout number five
he did it on three pitches to tyler
o'neill and that was pretty dominating
from corbin burns o'neill is strong as
they come
i'm sure there's an over under on
broadcasters saying that
his dad's a bodybuilder and tyler
o'neill comes from good stock
two two swing gonna miss at a curveball
and the inning is over o'neill trying to
say that he fouled it into the dirt he
did not another strikeout for corbin
burns it's his eighth we are through
five it's one nothing brewers corbin
burns so far has been spectacular five
innings of shutout baseball
he's giving up two hits on the season
two
a solo home run to byron buxton in his
first appearance and then the triple to
the first battery faced
today tommy edmond who was stranded at
third base he was there to lead off the
bottom of the first and then
strikeout pop-up fly out the 3-2 pitch
to tommy edmund
struck him out looking knee-high
fastball he comes all the way back for
strikeout number nine he was down on the
couch 3-0 and then just threw three
straight heaters right by tommy edmund
the last one
edmund couldn't pull the trigger so
corbin burns his day is done six innings
a hit no runs no walks and nine
strikeouts the final line for corbin
burns unfortunately for burns the
brewers in his two stars have only
scored one run that's amazing robertson
goes in to play second base i got a
feeling dan there's something there's
something about this game it's the first
time in busch stadium
fans have been in here since the nlcs
might not be this inning might not be
here
there's some magic today
[Applause]
the 0-1
o'neill hits it up the middle
stumbling race to the bag o'neal beats
it out the run scores
that's molina and we're tied 1-1
the brewers tried to get the out at
second base on williams who made it
safely and the way o'neal runs o'neill
earned an rbi out of it here comes
aronado they want to get loud here dan
they want to get loud everybody's going
to come out they want to come out and
cheer
arenado a drive deep left at the wall
welcome to saint louis nolan
and opening day home run
nolan arunado dean leads it first
aronado hits it deep left field back to
the track the wall it's a gunner
two run homer no
homers
or not a touch of the mall boy what an
opening day this is honey
bar tobias
is the first batter he is over two of
the walk
line past arenado and a base hit into
left
and the tying run will come to the plate
daniel vogelbach
in position perfectly as he knocks it
down
makes the play and gets a key first out
he had just moved
towards the outfield grass
fly ball
center field
this will do it carlson there and the
cardinals take
the home opener
3-1
and a day in which nolan orinato with a
blast late in his home debut